My major reasons for coming to Japan and choosing to take a gap year...
...were basically that I wanted to decide what I wanted to do,...
...whether I wanted to study medicine, and I'm really glad I took the time off...
...and took the opportunity to experience the field...
...before committing myself to studies.
It's really important to realize how much you can get out of this experience-wise.
It's just so exciting overseas and surrounded by different people,...
...surrounded by a different culture, throwing myself in the deep end...
...and trying something new.
The hardest part is putting yourself out there and getting in there...
...and doing the hard work because obviously, it's not easy all the time,...
...but that's kind of a point.
I've grown just in the last four months so much as a person.
My confidence has skyrocketed...
...and that's what being in Japan and doing this placement has taught me.